Fasting is a Muslimonly prerogative. Is
that correct?
>> That's right. It is compulsory only for
a Muslim to fast. It is not a
requirement for a non-Muslim or
unbeliever to fast. And the reason is
that Allah says in the Quran, Allah says
in surah nur chapter number 24 verse
number 39 that the deeds of a
non-believer a person who is a
non-Muslim the deeds of an unbeliever is
like a mirage in a desert and the
thirsty person thinks that there is
water but when he reaches there he does
not find anything else but he finds
Allah and Allah will pay him for his
deeds and Allah is swift in taking of
accounts. That means in the hereafter
the unbeliever for his deeds he will get
nothing and Allah is swift in taking of
accounts. So for unbeliever all the
deeds they are useless in the hereafter
because all the deeds have to be
accompanied with the intention and as we
discussed
yesterday that one of the criteria an
important criterion for a person's fast
to be accepted is the nia. It is
intention and the intention is that the
fast should only be for Allah subhanana
wa tala and no one else. So if a
non-Muslim, if unbeliever who does not
believe in Allah subhanana wa ta'ala,
where is the question of him doing the
nia, doing the intention of fasting for
Allah subhanaa tala? So that's the
reason it is not required for unbeliever
to fast. If he fast without the
intention, it will just be like anything
else. It will not be an act of worship.
It not be a fast as is considered in
Islam. So therefore the nia the
intention is very important. So for
unbeliever any act of worship until he
has faith until he believes until he
believes that there is only one Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala unless he says the
Muhammad rasool Allah that there's no
god but Allah and prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him is the messenger of Allah
all acts of worship they're useless for
the hereafter but the moment a
non-believer a person who's not a Muslim
he accepts Islam for him it becomes
obligatory if accepts Islam in the
middle of the month of Ramadan. From
that moment onwards, fasting becomes
compulsory for him. But the past Allah
will not take into account. Allah says
in the Quran,
Allah says in surah Anfal chapter number
8 verse number 38 that say to the
unbelievers that if they start believing
the past will be forgiven. That means
the moment a non-Muslim accepts Islam
all his past sins will be forgiven. But
the moment he accepts Islam from that
time it becomes obligated on him to
fast.